Hi, I'm John Webkey and I'm a Scoutmaster with 2.358 in Signsville, Indiana.
This edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster.
So we're out camping. last weekend,
Friday night, Scouts are setting up.
One of my brand new, newly trained Scouters comes up to me.
He's holding a two liter bottle of soda in one hand and a shell in the other
And he asks: do you think a foot is deep enough?
And I look at him. I have no idea what he's talking about.
And I said deep enough for what
He said. for the soda, of course,
I figured, you know, burying it a foot deep was enough.
Once again, I'm looking at him.
I have no idea what you mean.
He said: well, you know, I just got done with training and they said at every
overnight activity we have to have two liters deep.
Is a foot deep enough?
I kind of like that one.
Your mileage may vary, but the creditor Blaine goes to Steve Jackson
from Venture Crew 84 in Rollin, Missouri.
Thanks, Steve.
Hey, this is podcast number 272..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Greene.
Let's see here.
Hey, it's June
And I know like a lot of you are headed off to summer camp, or just
got back from summer camp, or are at summer camp right now.
So you know, hey, let's, let's take it easy,
Let's have an easy breezy podcast today.
What do you say?
Well, first we'll start out by looking in the mailbag.
I got this message from Dominic Carrigliano.
He said: discovered your podcast just yesterday and I enjoy listening to them.
I'm a little behind.
I've only gotten up to number 13..
Well, that's pretty good in a day. Dominic,
You need to go outside.
Anyway, Dominic goes on to say: I was scouting for 32 years in New York.
We moved to Florida. after a number of years of being uninvolved,
My wife encouraged me to get back involved,
So I found a troupe,
I'm a committee member and I'm pushing 61.
So I'm not quite as active as I used to be. but your podcast
reminded me of old scouting ways of the 1960s to the 1990s.
And my wife has told our new scouts that I went to camp with Baden Powell.
so I show them a picture of Baden Powell.
I tell him he was my bunk buddy at camp.
But anyway, it's going to be a while before I catch up on the recent podcast,
but thanks for rattling my memory once again.
Well, thank you, Dominic.
It's always good to hear from folks.
I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast
Heard from Steve Jackson, who I told you before.
he's with Venture Crew 84 in Roland, Missouri,
and he contributed the quote- joke unquote-
that you heard just a minute ago.
So, like I said, you know credit or blame goes to Steve,
But he had this to say.
I've downloaded every episode of the podcast
and started all the way back with episode number one.
On a recent trip I became a member of the Centurion Club.
In other words, I've listened to your first 100 podcasts.
So, yeah, the Centurion Club.
I don't remember ever saying that there was a club,
but that sounds good. Steve,
I think that's a good idea.
If you want to be a member of the Centurion Club,
get in touch with Steve.
There are so many great tips and resources on the podcast.
It kind of got to be an expensive trip for me.
I stopped at every scout shop that I could find to see
if they carried the books that you and your guests talked about.
I picked up the AMC Guide to Outdoor Leadership by Alex Kosoff,
BP, The Two Lives of a Hero by Greenbar Bill
and a lot of Council's shoulder patches.
Yeah, it's dangerous to stop into too many scout shops there. Steve,
You know that now.
Since I couldn't find Working the Patrol Method,
I did order it online.
Thank you for the tremendous resources and for all the great podcasts.
Looking forward to listening to the other 172..
Well, good for you, Steve.
Thanks for getting in touch.
Thanks for the joke
And I'm glad I can keep you entertained
while you're out there driving around.
We have a couple live chat sessions this week,
as we are want to do on weekday mornings.
If you keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed,
you will see when we're going to be on live
at scoutmasterscgcom with a chat.
I heard from Philip, who is in Houston, Texas,
and he's a new transplant from the UK,
just relocated to Houston.
He's looking for an opportunity to get back
and re-involved with scouts.
So if you're in Houston and you'd like Philip to come
and give you a hand, get in touch with me
and I'll make sure that he gets a message.
I also heard from Eric,
who is an assistant scoutmaster for Troop 33
in Laurel, Maryland,
and there were tons of other folks
who've been on the podcast before
and I've called their names on past podcasts
and we call them frequent flyers,
So you know who you are.
Thanks for being on the live chat with me this past week.
Before I go any further,
I'm going to ask you a simple favor.
I need you to do something for me.
If you're a regular reader and listener
and if the resources that I've created have helped you
and you haven't already,
I'm asking you to return the favor
by becoming a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
The funds that I get from backers
go to cover the expenses of producing
and publishing everything at ScoutmasterCGcom,
including what you're listening to right now.
So go to ScoutmasterCGcom,
click the support link at the top of the page
and you can choose from a number of options
to help support this work.
We like to keep it free.
We like everybody to be able to get everything that we create,
and we do that through the backer program.
I want to take a moment to personally thank
Robert Steele and John Booth,
who became backers since our last podcast.
Once again, go to ScoutmasterCGcom,
become a backer this week
and I'll make sure to thank you during our next podcast.
Like I said a bit ago,
it's an easy, breezy summertime-
Everybody's at Summer Camp podcast.
So the remainder of the podcast
is going to be taken up with some email questions
that I've received over the past week
and that's going to about do it.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scouts music,
Scouts music.
We think it's a salute.
Oh, there's no doubt about it.
When I drop my mask, we've been shot.
and talking to the uniform.
cause, baby, I was born to be a scout.
Cause baby, I was born to be a.
Here comes the Scout Master. Drive a drive to Scoutville a little faster.
Stick on the gas. are we there yet? I want to build a bridge for my ego.
I need a letter. Send it by name
Email. that is, folks. And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Hey, Bill Chapman is the Scout Master of Troop 736 in Rancho Santa Margarita, California.
He said we seem to have a perennial problem with rowdy troop meetings.
It's kind of like it was the best of times and the worst of times scenario.
For example, at a recent troop meeting there was no pre-opening plan.
The Scouts did their opening as usual and skill instruction was really just the senior patrol leader
talking to Scouts about how to succeed a camp for about 15 minutes.
It would have taken him five minutes to do, but he had to continually stop and wait while everybody quit talking.
The patrol meetings that evening were actually focused on one really rowdy patrol
and our other two patrols just kind of floundered because there wasn't any plan for anything.
Right after the troop meeting, the patrol leaders council met for about a half hour
and they enthusiastically addressed problems like rowdiness,
which is a frequent topic of discussion at our patrol leaders council meetings.
At times I thought the whole evening was a total disaster.
The Scouts are all talking and yelling at once.
There's no respect given to the senior patrol leader.
I wanted to jump in and say stop the noise and chaos,
but I knew that that might just make things worse.
And after that evening a committee member said that they have actually visited other troops
that are really well behaved and said something like: you know, we need to learn how to do that.
As I drove home I thought about it and I have to question whether or not
the troops that are really well behaved are actually youth led or not.
I know adults think that Scouts ought to sit and behave and listen attentively,
but I don't know if that's the way boys naturally behave if they're running things.
Can you train youth leaders to get the troop to be revered and respectful,
or is that just not in the carts?
Does it come with practice in patients, or am I just wishing for something that I don't want?
Well, Bill, you know this is one of the things that I could talk about on every podcast,
and in one way or another, I guess that I do,
but a lot of this is a trick of perspective.
I think we need to remember that Scouts simply do not see and experience things as adults
because they're not adults.
And I know that sounds very simple and pedantic
and I don't mean it to sound snide or cynical,
but you know, that's the one thing that I have to remind myself of all the time.
My Scouts don't experience the world as adults because they're not
Pretty simple, huh.
So, Bill, there's a couple of things that tell me maybe this doesn't need to be fixed.
and to get an idea whether or not it does need to be fixed,
talk to your youth leadership and a few younger Scouts, you know,
and give them some big, open-ended questions like: how did the meeting go?
What do you think of tonight's meeting?
How did things go for you?
And just see what they have to say, because if they have something that's bothering them,
they're going to tell you and then you have something to work with.
But the standard response usually is: yeah, it was fun, you know, and that's about it.
From a Scout that's a thumbs up right,
And they might not be able to explain why it was fun, but they had a good time.
Maybe they learned a few things, but they got to do the work of Scouting
because they were there with their patrol, with their troop.
So ask those questions.
Don't try and tell them anything.
Don't tell them the way you feel or what you saw.
Ask them what they experienced.
Then you'll have an idea if there's anything really to fix.
But, like I said, there's a couple of things that indicate to me
that there's nothing necessarily that you need to fix here.
You had a bunch of Scouts at a meeting-
That indicates that they want to be there,
And you had your patrol leaders council get together
and they spent a half hour enthusiastically- your word- discussing things.
That sounds like a big win to me,
And I'm not saying we shouldn't have high expectations of our Scouts,
but what you explained to me, I think, is to be expected.
It's a little chaotic, It's very loud.
Scouts are not necessarily very respectful of their peers
when their peers are standing up and talking
And when they're in a big herd like that.
they're almost never going to become highly organized and efficient
at a troop level or in the big herd like that,
because the troop isn't really all that important.
Everything important happens in the patrol.
Patrols do get things done and they are loud and messy at doing them.
Sometimes it doesn't look like much.
You do have to look hard at what goes on to see what is happening.
But if you train your eye and you train your perspective
you get pretty good at seeing the positive things that are going on.
And you know you're right.
Ideally, from an adult perspective, we would like to see the Scouts
sitting with their hands folded neatly in their laps,
respectfully listening to the senior patrol leader,
like a garden club listening to someone telling them how to prune their roses.
But that would be very strange because you know for the most part
people the age of our Scouts. they're boisterous and rowdy
and they want to talk at the same time
And you know they're going to figure this out
and the senior patrol leader is going to get the message across.
but it's not going to be nice and neat like a garden club meeting.
And the other thing is we can't see what they're like when we aren't watching,
because there's an observer effect.
Your Scouts are just like you when you were a kid
and that can be a comforting or terrifying thought
depending on how you- what you were like as a kid.
So let's face it, we were all kids once.
It was a long time ago. but you know what?
Basically, things haven't changed all that much.
We knew how to appear, to pay attention, to be polite and respectful,
even when we weren't,
When we were just kind of hanging out with our friends.
we did not act like adults because we weren't adults,
We were just kids.
Our Scouts spend a huge percentage of their lives
sitting and paying attention respectfully.
They're capable of doing it and they get to practice doing that
for hours and hours every day at school.
It would be a shame if they didn't have an opportunity,
like Scouting, to do something a little bit different,
To get into the maelstrom and the chaos
and the noise of doing an activity
that isn't administered by adults but is led by their peers
And that's always going to be exciting and engaging
and fun for Scouts.
It's going to look like chaos to us,
But the thing to do is to begin to train your eye
and adopt a perspective where you can see Scouting at work
even in the midst of all that.
I got this question this past week
and, of course, due to the nature of the question
it's, the center will remain anonymous.
We discovered recently that we had made a mistake,
crediting a Scout with a position of responsibility
that didn't actually qualify for the rank.
Somehow we missed this, both at the Scout Master Conference
and the Board of Review, and went on
to award the rank to the Scout.
We discovered the mistake after that.
Now what do we do?
Before I tell you what to do or what not to do,
let me tell you something that I know
almost for a dead certainty. okay,
Of all the people listening to this podcast,
when they heard that you made a mistake
by crediting a Scout in a position of responsibility
that didn't actually qualify for the rank,
they nodded their heads and they said,
yep, been there before.
They probably have made a similar type of mistake.
So, most important thing,
you made a mistake. you're not alone.
This happens from time to time.
So you discover you've made a mistake
in advancing a Scout like this,
and now what do you do?
Well, the golden rule here,
according to me, is avoiding penalizing Scouts
for the mistakes of adults.
There was nothing about what happened
that was within the Scout's control,
so the Scout should not be affected
by the mistake that an adult made.
And what do you do next?
Well, I don't know that. I would necessarily
even tell the Scout a mistake was made
and I certainly wouldn't penalize him
for the mistake that I made in any way, shape or form.
This is a different story
if somebody was willfully or knowingly
trying to skirt a requirement.
but that's not the case here.
It was a simple error.
But this is a really good opportunity
to sit down with the adults involved
and say: look, you know what,
make sure that that doesn't happen again.
And that's the way I would handle it.
I'm sure there would be differing opinions
as to why I would do that,
but the concept of not penalizing Scouts
for the mistakes adults make-
I think if you go to the Guide to Advancement
and you read ready,
Here we go- 7.0.4.7,,
which is entitled
The Limited Recourse for Unearned Merit Badges,
You get the spirit of what I'm saying.
Let's not penalize Scouts for our mistakes.
As with anything, policy, procedure, advancement wise-
what you're hearing is my best advice,
based on my experience and my understanding.
Go to the resources, talk to people,
make sure that you get it right.
Don't just take my word for anything.
Get it sorted out for yourself too.
And I did hear back from the folks
that sent me the email and they said
thanks for the advice.
We were able to work with our advancement committee
and we agreed that the Scouts shouldn't be penalized.
So we're moving forward, and that was great to hear.
So I have one other email this week
from Danny, who's the Scoutmaster Troop 41,
and he wrote in to say
what happens to Scouts who quote
eagle out, unquote,
the ones who can't wait to get their eagle and run.
If a Scoutmaster knows this is about to happen,
what can he do?
I mean, we do want the rank of eagle
to mean something besides its time to go,
And it means a lot to us as adults.
so why don't Scouts seem to get it?
We just had the first guy advance to Eagle
since I've been Scoutmaster
And I don't really know if there's a question in here
that can be answered,
but it's been on my mind for a few weeks.
Well, Dan, I understand the feeling,
because we all want the rank of eagle to mean something,
And I think that causes us to get a little overheated
sometimes and talk about:
oh, this is really, really meaningful
and you really need to pay attention to it
and you really need to understand what's going on.
And we really want Eagle Scouts to act certain ways
and hold certain attitudes.
We really want to hand them that badge
and have a total transformation happen in their lives,
because we want the rank of eagle to mean something.
And I know exactly how you feel, Dan,
because I got befuzzled by this for a long time.
I wanted to see something more from my Eagle Scouts.
Basically, I really wanted them to act like adults
and to understand what I felt and what I understood.
But I got over it
because I came to understand two basic things.
There's only one standard for becoming an Eagle Scout
and that's the requirements.
Getting the requirements for Eagle done is challenging,
but it's fairly simple and straightforward.
There is no continuing qualification
for being an Eagle Scout once you've completed the requirements.
And the second thing that helped me get over this
was understanding that anybody who becomes an Eagle Scout
once they get the badge,
they spend the rest of their lives becoming an Eagle Scout-
Our Scouts who earn Eagle and their teenagers.
they haven't really finished anything but a set of requirements.
They're really just beginning.
The important thing to realize
is that once a Scout earns Eagle rank,
he begins the lifelong process of becoming an Eagle Scout.
Rather than trying to make them understand something
or projecting obligations on them,
ask them about what they already understand.
See what they have been thinking about,
And it may surprise you.
I learned that I would always be disappointed in Eagle Scouts
if I think that the award comes with a bunch of strings attached,
because it doesn't, and that's a good thing.
Eagle Scouts get to live their own lives.
Very few Scout-age boys think like mature adults,
because they aren't.
They have, hopefully, a long life ahead of them
to figure things out, just like you had and just like I had.
If we've done our work well as Scouters,
if they did, to become an Eagle Scout,
we'll inspire them to go on and become good people.
So I'm going to get up on my soapbox for a moment, please.
And, Danny, this isn't intended for you,
This is for everybody, and I don't think you're an old groany
complaining guy, but you brought this subject up,
so I want to preach for a moment
Now listen, this whole thing about quote
eagling out. unquote
is just another one of these stupid little phrases
that somebody started using ages ago
and has perpetuated itself
and gives old people like me
something to sit and grumble about
while we're at a picnic table at summer camp.
Well, you know, they just eagle out
These boys just anymore. they get the eagle badge
and then they leave and blah, blah, blah, blah.
Look, I've been around Scouting now
for about 35 years as an adult.
35 years ago people were saying that.
60 years ago people were saying that
Let's get over ourselves here,
So let's stop using stupid terms like that
and let's talk to our Scouts on an individual basis
and find out what they understand.
You're going to be surprised by what they understand.
They understand a lot.
And if you sit around and complain
and grouse about your Scouts,
well they're not going to talk to you,
because really, who wants to talk to a person like that?
Okay, back down off of the soapbox.
And once again, Danny, that wasn't intended for you,
But I did hear back from Danny.
He said: you know what I think I get it.
The badge is really just a beginning.
It's a springboard.
It's the start of a lifelong process
And I've never liked the term eagle doubt.
And Danny says I think it diminishes the Scout in the award
And maybe they're just kids,
Maybe they're just boys trying to become men
and they have to figure it out as they go.
I think you're right, Dan.
I think that's the key right
Is understanding that anything that we hand a boy
in the way of an award is a beginning.
They're not fully cooked yet
And once you've had the benefit- as I have- of watching them
grow up and become adults,
you get to understand that the influences that they had
in Scouting remain important to them
and have helped shape them into the people that they become.
You may not see it when they're 15 or 16
as clearly as you would like,
but hey, hang on, talk to them,
ask them what they understand
and then watch as they become adults.
You'll see that understanding demonstrated.
Wow, deep subjects, huh?
Hey, listen. if you have a comment or a question for me,
you can get in touch.
It's pretty easy to do
And you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
Thanks for listening to this 272nd edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
You can keep in touch by reading the blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and subscribing to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
on the vast panorama of social media outlets.
There's something like 9,200 folks
who like Scoutmaster Blog on Facebook.
There's about 1,200 people who tweet along with us on Twitter
And 2,000 folks pin the Pultritudinous Pictures
proffered publicly on Pinterest.
And we do have the quiet little circle
of 400 odd folks on Google+.
Now if you listen to that and you say,
ah man, I can't face Facebook
and Twitter makes me bitter.
I have no interest in Pinterest,
I don't put the? U in YouTube
and I'm a minus when it comes to Google+,
Look, don't worry about it.
You can zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email,
Get in touch with me with your comments and questions
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
Hey, I want to remind you that the Scoutmaster Blog
and the Scoutmaster Podcast
are only official publications of me.
They are not official publications
of any scouting organization,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization.
What I've done is I bought a microphone,
I have a laptop computer
and an internet connection
and that means now I am a podcaster
And all I'm trying to do
is lend a hand to my fellow Scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way,
And speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Well, thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.
Thank you.